do you think we did a good job oh yeah
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's okay it's
mom and all my kids are home right now
so this is my life cooking cooking
cooking cooking I did not realize how
much of my day would revolve around
cooking for my kids but I feel like by
the time I finished cooking and we've
all eaten and I've done dishes it's
already time to cook another dish so I'm
gonna try something because I'm tired of
it I'm going to outsource this task and
have my kids cook breakfast for a week
it'll be a fun opportunity for them to
get creative make the food they want
learn a little something and I get a
little break from one meal a day so wish
me luck
so first and foremost the rules most
importantly no waste absolutely no food
waste at all in my house this goes
pretty much without saying everyday but
I just want to make sure when the kids
have more freedom that they're not
trying to make food that's inedible and
I'm not making special grocery runs just
for little ingredients that they want
they've got to work with what we have in
our pantry fridge and freezer and the
final rule is nothing dangerous no
stovetop no oven nothing involving sharp
knives and if the kids need some help I
will help them good morning it is the
perfect morning to not have to cook
breakfast I'm so excited is breakfast
ready yeah so day 1 started off very
simple I think the boys saw a certain
item that I had purchased in the pantry
and I kinda knew they'd go for that
first oh my goodness
doughnut towers oh who cut this banana
Jackson color me impressed with little
markers oh that's
because they made donut towers are you
proud of yourself
yeah why in are you proud and I love how
you thought of you know health with the
banana yeah do you feel like you're a
police officer
mmm-hmm no I think the tower was kind of
a ploy to like have more doughnuts on
the plate cuz it's like a look we made
it into a tower how fancy I better eat
six day one so far so good
good morning it's a great morning to not
cook should we see what your brother's
came up with today hello are you cooking
you need my help okay I will reach the
bowls for you the following day the boys
decided to take things up a small notch
oh my goodness
this looks amazing who did the eggs
I cut it the egg you did did you season
them yeah and I pulled a little bit too
much on on this one they didn't hard
boil the eggs themselves they came
hard-boiled but why it did him up a real
nice what I started to notice is Jackson
kind of stepped into the role of head
chef and Wyatt took on the role of sous
chef so Jackson was delegating a lot of
tasks to Wyatt that Jackson knew why it
would be able to handle which was very
cool to see how is it cool I'm going for
the egg I'm going for the egg I'm gonna
give my cereal first did you mix two
different kinds Johnson whoo
bring my special egg hmm you know I
really should be raiding this food I
feel like on a scale of one to ten I'd
give that one a 7.5 it was very nice
good morning I realized that my mood
drastically improves when I wake up
knowing that somebody else is cooking
for me and the kids are actually happy
to do it so let's see what they have
prepared today I think they haven't
started cooking it so I better go remind
them hey guys where's my breakfast oh
[Music]
excuse me what kind of restaurant is
this after coasting a little bit with
pretty easy breakfast the next day the
boys decided to make something fancy
wait what did you say
[Music]
I'm gonna check on them I was trying not
to intrude too much on their cooking
process but I could hear Jackson
distinctly say oh no lots of seasoning
okay Laver do you want me to get this
toast out for you yes please okay not
quite toasted but what do we hope you so
they tried their hand at avocado toast
Wow
this color is nice yeah because we got
seasoning we got not know them n-no I
was really surprised that they picked
avocado toast because Wyatt notoriously
hates avocado thank you is why do take a
bite already it's delicious you should
be proud of yourself his reaction was a
little lackluster but he finished the
whole piece which is amazing and ever
since then he has been open to eating
avocado actually this just goes to show
that if kids are involved in the process
and they feel like they are
accomplishing something and it's their
hard work they're a lot more willing to
try it
alright I'm giving it a taste
[Music]
I didn't dislike the avocado toast it
was just there was a lot of salt like a
lot of salt I'm not gonna say I don't
like it it was my kids made it of course
I loved it I ate the whole thing
successful day good morning I hear the
kids in the kitchen let's see what
they're doing oh I'm making smoothie
you're making smoothies oh can I tell
you can I give you a little tip I don't
like yeah you need a liquid in here oh
I'll get some milk okay I hate that we
do that is it plain yeah well I think
that's why Jackson got the honey out
yeah what you need put honey why it's
serving technique is not up to code in
terms of restaurant cleanliness but he's
my kid if he wants to lick the spoon
that's fine we wash our hands very
thoroughly before anybody touches any
food gosh look at this presentation wow
that looks like Greek yogurt with honey
and granola and are those dried cherries
yeah let me see you I better than mine
this is really good
great job guys yes overall that meal is
what I would make myself if I had my way
for breakfast high five what and I was
very impressed
good morning I hear a bunch of commotion
outside what are you doing
where's breakfast
are you guys getting along yes yeah okay
day five was when things got weird what
is happening
what were you putting in the toaster
while I was back to put the plate in the
toaster you were about to put the plate
in the toaster yes oh my god
you want to set a fire and a waffle did
you mean to leave the waffle a little
frozen mm-hmm Jackson made a point of
saying over and over and over and I
meant to leave it a little frozen and I
meant to leave it a little frozen I
totally meant to make to walk which kind
of frozen normally meant to do that did
he didn't mean to leave it a little
present overall not a meal that I would
ever make again or serve my children but
they tried it they got it out of their
system and I think that's what matters
five out of ten good morning Morgan's
this is sneak peek into breakfast
Wyatt watch out oh my gosh as weird as
the waffles and talkies were as a combo
the following day was also a very
creative breakfast Jackson what is this
it's toast on a burger bun and do some
yummy beans
[Music]
means cheese and salsa on a burger bun
yeah I don't know where they got the
idea but Jackson really was dead set on
making a specific dish
let's try Wyatt try yours is it good
what do you think it's [ __ ] mine the
laundry behind him
not bad so did I actually like the
refried bean cheese salsa hamburger bun
open-faced toast sandwich yes yes I did
ten out of ten would eat again I'm not
going in there
I don't want to know if I could use one
word to describe the next day it would
be um are we doing in here
we made a nice mixture look at this nice
mixture of kick we put it on boy I
thought oh no it's a nice very blue I
was really hoping they wouldn't try
baking because it's such a science and I
didn't want anything to go to waste and
I wasn't sure if I'd be able to save a
baking fail do you need eggs
yes eggs eggs eggs did you oh did you
put in this yeah how much Oh a little
bit a tablespoon it's one yeah one thing
oh that's a lot Jackson how much of this
did you put it what 1 tablespoon wait
what is a tablespoon 1 tablespoon show
me this is one piston
that's a actual tablespoon okay what
actually surprised me is they did get a
lot of key ingredients correct they got
the flour they got some oil they new
sugar they new baking powder and soda
maybe not both in such a ginormous
imbalance but they knew to use these
things for baking so that was really
cool and it just showed me that they pay
attention when we're baking together and
that it's an activity that actually
teaches them something maybe get some
eggs maybe a little more flour usually
you do like sugar and butter butter
butter butter you want it all do you
think we did a good job oh yeah can I
smell right what you like it soaked oh
you want to add some chocolate chip yeah
I was very nervous because I didn't know
how much baking powder and soda was
actually in there I was afraid that
things might overflow I was afraid that
it might explode but when the cake came
out of the oven the results were
shocking all right
the cakes are green we're gonna let
these corn letting it cool for a little
bit but it's not quite there Wow
[Music]
okay this actually looks like a cake it
was delicious
it was delicious mama you want to know
the best part that what is then the best
part is because there's like chocolate
hidden in the cake oh yeah this entire
week was a big confidence boost for both
of my kids each time he made food that
he felt was successful he would say out
loud I'm really proud of myself that's
all a parent wants to hear it
what mm-hmm so that's all I got for
today I'm Hannah and if you try this
make sure you tag me on Instagram
because I want to see your kids
creations or if you have any other
activities for me to try with my kids
send me a message on Instagram too and
if you'll please excuse me I'm gonna go
cook my own food because my kids are
taking a well-deserved break
till next time
[Music]